CURTSYING THE QUEEN.
>> Tucker: FATHER, THANK YOU.
>> ALWAYS A PLEASURE.
>> Tucker: IF YOU'VE WATCHED A
WHITE HOUSE PRESS BRIEFING, SHE
DISLIKES A SPECIFIC REPORTER
FROM AFRICA, WORKING WITH TODAY
NEWS.
HE'S HAD A LOT OF HOSTILE
ENCOUNTERS.
YESTERDAY SHE STORMED OUT OF THE
OUT OF THEPRESS CONFERENCE, ENDT
EARLY.
HERE'S SOME CLIPS FROM IT.
>> I HEAR YOUR QUESTION, BUT
WE'RE NOT DOING THIS THE WAY YOU
WANT IT.
THIS IS THE DISRESPECTFUL.
I'M DONE.
SIMON, I'M DONE.
SIMON, I'M DONE WITH YOU RIGHT
NOW.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN NOT DOING
ANYTHING WHEN PROTESTERS WANT
THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES TO --
>> TO SAY THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE,
THAT IS -- THAT IS JUST
UNBELIEVABLY WRONG.
I'M MOVING ON.
I'M TRYING TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
GO AHEAD, SIR.
GO AHEAD.
I JUST TRIED.
YOU WOULDN'T LET ME.
YOU WOULD NOT LET ME, SIR.
SO YOUR COLLEAGUE IS GOING TO
ASK A QUESTION.
>> CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION?
>> NO.
I LITERALLY TRIED TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
YOU SHUT ME DOWN.
THANKS, EVERYBODY.
I'LL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
>> Tucker: IT'S A GOOD THING
SHE'S UNARMED, OR HE'D BE IN
DEEP TROUBLE.
HE'S A CORRESPONDENT FOR TODAY
NEWS AFRICA, OBVIOUSLY KIND OF A
HERO, AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
YOU COULD FEEL IT WATCHING THAT
TAPE, SHE'S MAD AT YOU.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> YES.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU, TUCKER,
FOR HAVING ME ON YOUR SHOW.
THERE'S A REASON WHY YOUR SHOW
IS THE MOST WATCHED SHOW IN NEWS
IN THE U.S. BECAUSE YOU BRING
PEOPLE LIKE ME, IT'S BEEN A
DISASTER, A CATASTROPHE,
COVERING THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE.
RIGHT NOW I'M THE VOICE OF
AFRICA IN THE U.S.
BUT I CAN CONFIRM THAT THE LEVEL
OF DISCRIMINATION AGAINST ME AND
AGAINST AFRICAN JOURNALISTS IN
THE WHITE HOUSE IS ASTOUNDING,
DISGRACEFUL.
YOU KNOW, IT'S BEEN THREE MONTHS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE QUESTIONS AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
EVEN AS PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ABOUT
TO RECEIVE AFRICAN HEADS OF
STATE, SHE DIDN'T GIVE US A
SINGLE QUESTION.
I'VE BEEN TRYING FOR THE PAST
THREE MONTHS.
IT'S SHOCKING, BECAUSE SHE'S
BLACK.
SHE'S AN IMMIGRANT.
I'M BLACK.
I'M ALSO AN IMMIGRANT.
IT'S SHOCKING.
SHE SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF HERSELF
FOR DOING THAT.
AND IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
>> Tucker: SHE'S OBVIOUSLY A
BIGOT.
YOU CAN SEE IT IN HER FACE.
SHE REALLY DISLIKES YOU.
DO YOU SUPPOSE BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE THE SAME VIEWS THAT SOMEONE
WHO LOOK LIKE YOU SHOULD HAVE,
IN HER OPINION?
>> YES.
SO I BELIEVE THAT IT HAS TO DO
WITH TWO OR THREE THINGS.
THE FIRST THING, I SOUND
DIFFERENT.
I WASN'T BORN HERE.
I WAS BORN IN CAMEROON.
I SPEAK 47.
I SPEAK DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
I DON'T HAVE THE AMERICAN
ACCENT.
I'VE TRIED.
I'VE FAILED.
I'LL STICK WITH MY ACCENT.
I'M AN IMMIGRANT.
I ASKED HER, HOW IS IT
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS INVITING 50 AFRICAN
HEAD OF STATE TO THE U.S. WHO
HAS SPENT ALMOST $50 MILLION
EACH AND HE DOESN'T HAVE FIVE
MINUTES TO SPEND ABOUT EACH OF
THEM?
HE WON'T HAVE AND ONE WITH ANY
OF THOSE AFRICAN PRESIDENTS
COMING HERE, IN COUNTRIES WHERE
MONEY IS A BIG PROBLEM?
WHY NOT HAVE A MEETING ON ZOOM,
FOR INSTANCE.
SO I ASKED QUESTIONS ABOUT
COVID.
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THAT
1 MILLION PEOPLE EVEN HAVE TO GO
BY OFFICIAL FIGURES, 1 MILLION
AMERICANS WERE KILLED BY COVID,
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHERE COVID
CAME.
YOU LIED TO US.
YOU TOLD US THAT COVID CAME FROM
BAT TO HUMAN, AND NOW WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT PROBABLY CAME
FROM THE LAB.
THAT'S THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
QUESTION.
SHE WOULDN'T EVEN ALLOW THAT
QUESTION TO BE ASKED.
NO.
YOU NEED TO ALLOW THE QUESTION.
IT IS DISGREAT $GRACEFUL.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE ALW